in normal times roughly 40 percent of  fresh vegetables at about 40 percent  China are embassies in Kenya and  Tanzania nambia's health system is  increasingly self-sufficient shifting  production to Thailand and to Vietnam  Thailand and Vietnam this is not about  virtue cycling and signing and the great  General and President  Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really  come back a long way over the last 10  years hasn't he  country we appreciate it very much Tim  Apple when they gaze upon your semites  your seminites towering Sequoias they  delivered a Swift and swept in you know  that sweeping it was Swift and it was  sweeping like nobody's  ever seen anything happen